accueillons monsieur thierry des au
directeur général de la société indienne
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues depuis l'annnonce de veolia
fin août de racheter les parts détenues
par angie dans suez
la fusion envisagée entre les deux
groupes alimente un feuilleton boursier
judiciaire riche en rebondissements dont
la presse économique se fait largement
l'écho et à laquelle nous ne prendrions
pas par si les gens je n'étais pas aussi
vitaux pour notre pays bien entendu nous
n'entendons pas intervenir dans un
conflit économique et boursier entre
deux sociétés privées mais en tant que
parlementaires et représentants des
collectivités territoriales
nous nous interrogeons sur les
conséquences de cette opération entre
les deux acteurs dominants de la gestion
de l'eau et des déchets en france nous
interrogeons sur les emplois nous
interrogeons sur la qualité du service
pour les collectivités et ainsi que pour
les usagers
c'est pourquoi nos deux commissions
décidé de mettre en place un comité de
suivi comité de suivi composé de six
sénateurs qui possède depuis novembre
dernier à l'audition d'un certain nombre
de parties prenantes et d'experts nora
porter je n'en doute pas ne manquerons
pas de vous poser un certain nombre de
questions afin de poursuivre nos travaux
nous entendons aujourd'hui en réunion
plénière en commun la commission des
affaires économiques monsieur thierry
des au président de mary gamme monsieur
le président vous avez fondé et dirigé
depuis 2005 meridiam société a mission
gérant sept fonds thématique et
géographique pour un total de 8
milliards de dollars d'actifs
votre expertise est reconnue sur la
place parisienne vos investissements
s'articule autour du développement du
financement et de la gestion des projets
d'infrastructures publiques sur le long
terme
vous avez noué un partenariat avec
veolia est pressenti pour reprendre
l'activité de suez aux france que veolia
devrait céder si la sab suez devait
aboutir
afin de respecter le caractère
concurrentiel du secteur de l'eau en
france et ainsi satisfaire aux exigences
que poserait à coup sûr le régulateur
européen suez ou en france et plus de 4
millions de clients
10 millions et demi de français
desservis en eau potable et près de 10
millions bénéficiant de l'assainissement
ces chiffres donnent une idée de la
grande responsabilité qui pèsera sur
votre groupe en matière de qualité et de
continuité de services d'innovation et
de maîtrise des prix pour les
consommateurs cela conduit à vous poser
une première série de questions disposez
vous de la structure financière du
savoir faire et de l'horizon nécessaire
pour reprendre l'activité d'une société
exerçant depuis plus de 140 ans dans son
secteur
quels moyens comptez vous déployez pour
poursuivre la continuité de ses services
essentiels pour nos territoires de pour
nos concitoyens
qu'avez vous à dire pour rassurer les
collectivités qui se disent très
inquiètes
concernant leur choix futurs en matière
de délégation de service public dans le
secteur de l'eau et le secteur de
l'assainissement
vous êtes engagé à préserver l'emploi
sur cinq ans a tenté de votre prise de
contrôle
vous avez également proposé d'allouer
jusqu'à 10% du capital aux salariés et
d'accroître de 800 millions d'euros les
investissements de l'entité suez
reprises ses engagements nous sommes
bien entendu nous semble aller dans le
bon sens car les défis posés par la
transition écologique nécessite
d'importants moyens financiers et un
horizon d'investissement à long terme
cependant un article de mediapart d'une
février dernier vous dit sous pression
de vos actionnaires pareille affirmation
est de nature à éveiller notre méfiance
comment réagissez vous à ces allégations
et aurez vous les mains suffisamment
libre pour vous inscrire dans la
temporalité longue exigé par le secteur
de l'eau auprès de quel investisseur
procédez-vous au lever de fonds
nécessaires à la reprise de l'activité
aux france de suez
si celle ci devait se faire le projet de
rapprochement entre veolia suez nous a
réservé
ces derniers mois et semaines un grand
nombre de surprises et d'évolution
imprévus quelle lecture faites vous
aujourd'hui de la situation et
qu'attendez-vous des événements à venir
comment envisagez vous les prochaines
étapes pour veolia et votre groupe
êtes vous optimiste quant à une issue
positive qui satisfait ce qui satisfasse
toutes les parties prenantes de ce
dossier vous pensez vous au contraire
que ce duel entre deux champions du
capitalisme français ne peut se résoudre
par la voie boursière habituel à savoir
la prise de décisions par les conseils
d'administration et actionnaire
intéressés mais se dénouera par une
décision de justice à l'issue d'une
bataille homérique qui durera encore
longtemps vous voyez monsieur le
président nous sommes impatients de vous
entendre et de nous entendre répondre à
nos légitimes interrogations que
l'ensemble des sénateurs et à travers
eux nombre de français se posent
je vous remercie de sa part aussi à dire
quelques mots essayer de pas être
redondantes monsieur le président le jo
monsieur le président chers collègues
souvent qu'on considère votre fonds
d'investissement on l'appelle d'ailleurs
plutôt un fonds d'infrastructure parce
que vous avez la réputation sur le
marché d'être un investisseur patients
je crois que vous nous direz peut-être
aucune aucune de vos participations
aujourd'hui n'a été revendue et vous dit
assez facilement votre horizon se situe
à 25 ans qui évidemment dans la sphère
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui est un atout
considérable alors comme l'a dit le
président longeau vous êtes mêlée
aujourd'hui à une guerre un peu
fratricide de deux grandes entreprises
françaises qui sont vraiment deux
grandes entreprises mondiales celle qui
oppose veolia à suez
puisqu'à la fin de l'été 2020 veolia
annoncé son projet d'acquisition de suez
projet auquel vous êtes étroitement
associés puisque vous vous porteriez
acquéreurs mais peut-être que le
conditionnel est encore à ahmed vous
porteriez acquéreur de la branche suez
aux france dont veolia serait obligé de
se séparer pour respecter des règles de
concurrence vous étiez déjà partenaire
de veolia et de suez dans d'autres
projets
d'infrastructures peut-être pouvez-vous
nous dire quelles sont les motivations
qui vous ont porté à sortir de votre
positionnement d'ordinaire plutôt
prudent pour devenir partie prenante
d'une au pea qualifiés et à juste titre
aujourd'hui
d'hostile voix dynamique al désormais
bien parce que pas aussi bien par serait
ce que par le ministère de l'économie
elles tiennent sans nous douter un
projet mûrement réfléchie voilà voudrais
savoir quel est ce projet mûrement
réfléchie vous disposez monsieur des
eaux d'une expérience et d'une expertise
unanimement reconnue dans le champ des
infrastructures aussi je ne vous
apprendrai rien vous rappelant que suez
aux france vous seriez le repreneur est
l'un des fleurons français il est bien
sûr l'héritier de la lyonnaise des eaux
et de ce qu'on appelle un peu
pompeusement mais je crois juste titre
l'école française de l'eau seulement si
cette opération venait à aboutir avec
veolia après le temps de l'association
qui est le temps actuel viendra celui de
la compétition il vous faudra résister à
la concurrence d'un veolia qui serait un
acteur plus grand que vous plus depuis
sans peut-être que vous et devenir
al'inverse son meilleur ennemi
c'est donc d'abord à vos performances à
la tête de l'ancien suez offrant ce que
dépendra la structure concurrentielle de
notre marché français vous aurez la
responsabilité d'empêcher l'émergence de
ce que nous redoutons c'est-à-dire un
quasi monopole dans l'assainissement
l'approvisionnement en eau service au
combien essentielle pour notre
territoire et pour la transition
écologique et comme il n'y aura ne vous
aura pas échappé que dans cette maison
des collectivités nous tiennent à coeur
nous sommes très heureux de vous
entendre voilà sur ce sujet alors les
interrogations existent quant à la
capacité d'un fonds de gestion d'actifs
comme le vôtre à passer à la gestion
directe des biens publics il s'agit là
d'un projet industriel d'ailleurs
monsieur frérot le dis souvent comme
vous comment vous êtes vous préparé en
interne à cette opération d'ampleur qui
vous coûtera la bagatelle de 3 milliards
d'euros
peut-être plus puisque dans les
dernières discussions on parle d'un
élargissement de l'accord sur peut-être
cinq sur peut-être 6 milliards comment
est ce que vous vous préparez à cela
disposez vous de l'expérience suffisante
pour gérer l'approvisionnement en eau de
millions de foyers en somme
aurez vous les reins assez solides face
à véolia ces dernières semaines vous
n'avez eu de cesse que de
souligné les paradoxes de la
contre-offre remonté en janvier
alors on a un retour cas c'est bon
bizarre voilà vous n'avez de cesse que
de souligner les paradoxes de la
contre-offre monté en janvier par suez
avec ardeur et j -p
et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs monsieur frérot
s'exprime en disant il ya d'un côté un
projet industriel français et de l'autre
côté un projet financier américain face
à cette contre-offre vous avez plusieurs
fois évoqué des engagements que vous
prendriez rocade rachat de la branche
eau quand il s'agit d'infrastructures
aussi essentiels que cela il ne suffit
pas de donner des arguments il faut des
solides assurances au vu des dossiers
économiques récents nous savons que les
engagements n'engage parfois que ceux
qui les croient
pourriez-vous nous répondre précisément
sur la nature juridique de ces
engagements s'agit-il de déclarations
publiques ou avez vous signé un document
avec véolia éventuellement avec l'état
français qui listent ses engagements de
matières manière détaillée seriez vous
prêt si ce n'est pas encore le cas
signer un tel contrat sous peine de
nullité de l'opération voilà les
questions cache un peu que l'on vous
pose le sur le président-directeur
général dans cette affaire qui vous
l'avez compris nous préoccupe au plus
haut point notamment pour les
collectivités mais aussi pour la
grandeur industriel de notre pays
bonjour à tous
madame la présidente monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs tout d'abord je souhaite vous
remercier de l'opportunité de venir
répondre à vos questions
c'est un honneur et c'est une
opportunité aussi pour présenter à la
fois meridiam ses réalisations sa
mission ses capacités ses engagements
pour suez aux france
et si cette opération de rachat de
veolia va à son goût j'ai fondé meridiam
10 à 15 ans donc avec une ferme
conviction que qu'un outil
d'investissement de long terme était
nécessaire pour investir dans les
territoires avec les parties prenantes
et les élus et cela après une carrière
d'ingénieur des ponts commencé
d'ailleurs dans le groupe lyonnaise des
eaux sous les jets
de jérôme monod au service du bien
public ensuite à la caisse des dépôts en
qualité de maître d'ouvragé de maître
d'oeuvre de gestionnaires de services de
publique de transports une caisse des
dépôts qui m'a offert l'opportunité à
l'âge de 31 ans dirigé l'une de ses
filiales d'ingénierie et de services de
plusieurs milliers d'employés depuis
meridiam a investi plus de 65 milliards
et continue de d opérer dans 26 pays
contrôlent un portefeuille de 90
sociétés employant à peu près 8000
personnes un peu plus et opère dans la
mobilité des biens et des personnes
l'environnement et la transition
écologique les équipements publics
sociaux et grâce à une équipe un terme
de 300 personnes dont une large majorité
de spécialistes et d'ingénieurs venant
l'industrie du service public notamment
de l'eau et dans des opérations
évidemment et des entreprises de toutes
tailles
en france nous avons investi et
continueront d'opérer plus de 12
milliards d'euros dans des entreprises
et des projets parmi lesquels le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le port de
calais les lignes lgv tours bordeaux ou
nîmes montpellier dont nous sommes
l'actionnaire contrôlant est majoritaire
aussi la l2 qui a permis le
désenclavement des quartiers nord de
marseille mais aussi au plus près des
collectivités des agriculteurs nous
avons le premier réseau de production et
de services de méthanisation
territoriale en france opéré par la
société ever gaz que nous accompagnons
dans son développement de plus de
plusieurs années société a mission et
ang acteur engagé dans le développement
durable
nous plaçons la performance
extra-financière au même niveau que la
performance financière et nous n'avons
vendu comme vous l'avez dit aucun actif
depuis 15 ans dans cette optique de
performance extra-financière au terme de
cette expérience
ce que nous voulons pour suez aux france
est un projet centré sur la transparence
du service aux collectivités
sur l'innovation au service du
consommateur et la gestion de la
ressource eau qui est la principale
préoccupation des élus locaux mais c'est
la principale préoccupation face aux
changements climatiques et aux
transformations de notre planète et de
notre pays en particulier
alors nos engagements quels sont ils
c'est un projet industriel pour pour
suez ou aux france c'est la construction
avec ses offenses d'un acteur
international un champion de l'eau et
différenciées dans ce secteur de l'eau
l'eau et l'environnement font partie
d'une stratégie nationale aujourd'hui
qui est portée par la france avec force
depuis la coop 21 et qui pourra compter
sur un acteur et un champion français de
l'eau le climat est un enjeu essentiel
pour le service public de l'eau qui
devra s'adapter et l'urgence en la
matière comme l'a bien fait remarquer
les assises de l'eau qui ont eu lieu il
ya pas très longtemps
nous ne sommes pas prêts et des
investissements massifs sont requis
notre engagement est que l'épargné des
français que nous investissons grâce aux
institutions comme les assureurs les
caisses de retraite ou les mutualistes
qui nous la collecte et qui nous l'a
confie cette ce capital et l'épargné des
français devra représenter 60 à 70% du
capital de suez pour 25 ans au mois donc
c'est un engagement d'un projet français
possédé par l'épargné française
l'eau est un secteur dans lequel nous
croyons et que nous connaissons certes j
ai commencé ma carrière mais depuis 2007
une quinzaine de collaborateurs issus de
ce secteur travaille pour toutes les
opérations que nous avons dans le
secteur de l'eau et de l'environnement
ce qui nous a valu des succès notamment
aux etats-unis dans l'eau et ailleurs ou
dans l'environnement ailleurs en europe
et aussi des échecs puisque nous avons
était finaliste mais non gagnant 2
du rachat de la société saur nous allons
donc préserver les emplois et les
compétences et cela c'est important dans
notre projet industriel et nous
souhaitons porter ce projet avec le
management et le et le corps social de
suez aux france car nous avons besoin de
lui nous sommes un actionnaire
investisseurs qui les accompagnera dans
le développement de l'entreprise
nous ne sommes pas un opérateur à sa
place notamment je pense que sont son
actionnaire qui a vendu ses 29% ne
participe pas directement mais je pense
que nous serons plus actif que cet
actionnaire nous sommes à la fois un
actionnaire actif parce que nous sommes
capables de nous impliquer
évidemment au coeur des problématiques
stratégiques mais au coeur des
problématiques opérationnelles et social
et nous avons aussi capacité de mettre à
disposition de suez aux français de
cette plateforme qui se voudra
internationale notre réseau d'innovation
et notre réseau international
d'innovation et d'activités connexes à
cette entité celui de meridiam au sein
de 26 pays donc au sein de suez aux
france
tous les emplois seront préservés et
vous l'avez dit pour une durée minimale
de cinq ans et nous nous engageons même
dans l'objectif de la transmission des
savoir-faire et des compétences à créer
un centre de formation national et
embaucher mais l'apprenti
supplémentaires dès la première année
nous sommes un investisseur de long
terme très patient indépendant des
résultats trimestriels que demande la
bourse et regardant notre rentabilité à
25 ans nous ne sommes pas des
spéculateurs en quête de plus value
rapide et les territoires les plus
ruraux ont autant besoin
d'investissement et des services de
l'eau que les métropoles en ce sens
aucun arbitrage dans l'esprit de mary
gamme ne devra de rentabilité ne se fera
sur la base rurale contre métropole
par ailleurs nos projets dans les
territoires ruraux au service de la
transition écologique en mayenne dans le
morbihan vendée dans les deux sèvres
encore pas loin de toulouse ou dans les
ardennes sont les meilleurs témoins de
notre attachement au développement des
services publics partout nous sommes
aussi de farouches opposants puisque
vous parlez de capacité de tout
endettement excessif que d'autres
opérateurs on peut subir je les ai nommé
plutôt suez au sera une société
souveraine métriques maîtresse de son
destin industriels précisément parce que
nous allons la soutenir de manière
privilégiée avec des fonds propres de
très long terme la dette de la société
sera donc maintenue à un niveau
soutenable selon les critères des
agences de notation afin de ne pas
obérer ses capacités d'investissement
nous faisons un pari industriel
ambitieux en investissant 860 millions
supplémentaires sur une période de cinq
à sept ans pour l'innovation dans
l'outil industriel de suez le
développement technologique la recherche
le cycle de l'eau et la ressource nous
allons garder si cette opération se fait
et développer le sire c'est le
laboratoire bordelais dû lire les
centres de recherche renommé ainsi que
toutes les capacités de gréement et suez
international pour la construction afin
d'assurer aux collectivités une offre
pleinement diversifiée et qui répondent
à nos défis collectifs en particulier
sanitaire et écologique plus plus
récents nous intégrerons aussi suez sa
smart solutions et sur le métier de la
valorisation des biodéchets et des boues
de step dans lequel nous sommes déjà
leader en france suez organique
j'ai eu l'occasion et je vais conclure
ici pour vous laisser le temps de me
poser plus de questions et peut-être de
répondre plus précisément à vos question
d'échangé pendant plus de 10 à 12 heures
cumulées ces dernières semaines avec les
représentants des cs des différentes
entités leurs craintes
dans cette incertitude sont légitimes
nous avons eu
des discussions franches et ouvertes et
il me semble que notre ambition après ça
est toujours intacte pour eux et nous
leur avons proposé par ailleurs de
contrôle est la tenue de nos engagements
que nous prendrons part écrit que nous
avons déjà pris par écrit en adressant
un courrier à angie à l'état lors de la
première transaction d'octobre mais à
travers ses engagements écrits nous
souhaitons que le cdc et ce contrôle un
observatoire qui puisse contrôler la
tenue de nos engagements au fil de l'eau
et plus loin encore un observatoire qui
soit l'organe de pilotage de la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et des
compétences au sein du nouveau groupe
je vous remercie et je suis disponible
et à votre disposition pour plus de
questions merci monsieur le président je
pense qu'il y aura des questions
évidemment supplémentaires je vais
laisser la parole dans un premier temps
à catherine fournier est en visio devant
nous sur le président oui merci madame
la présidente revient à bonjour bonjour
et bonjour monsieur le président eh bien
je reviendrai si vous permettez sur les
engagements de mérite ya peu de temps
après l'adoption de la loi pattes vous
vous êtes doté de statut d'entreprise a
mission et vous de releviez vous nous
d'expliquer comment cela se traduit-il
dans la gestion du fonds et des projets
dans lesquels vous avez vous vous
investissez
est ce pour cette raison que vous avez
déclaré être prêt à prendre des
engagements dans le cadre de ce rachat
la branche eau de suez vous seriez ainsi
prêt à engager 800 millions d'euros
d'investissements dans la branche eau de
suez pouvez vous nous indiquer à ce
triste
à ce titre si les activités au kivu
seraient cédés inclurait le contrôle des
centres de recherche et développement de
suez au vous parliez tout à l'heure de
665 millions supplémentaires je ne sais
pas si ce serait inclus dedans ou si
ceux ci resterait dans le périmètre de
veolia après la fusion
voilà monsieur le président
silva très récente je vais te donner la
parole aux rapporteurs de la commission
d'aménagement du territoire
je favreau tu veux prendre la parole au
président directeur général sur jeu ma
position n'est pas n'est pas conforme au
positionnement de mon micro j'en suis
désolé
simplement nous sommes dans un contexte
effectivement un peu particulier puisque
la la la forme même que vous avez
souhaité de votre entreprise qui n'en
fait pas un fonds d'investissement
ordinaire et qui a une vision à long
terme fait que dans un contexte par
ailleurs qui n'est pas d'une clarté
totale dans la lutte qui oppose
aujourd'hui les dirigeants de veolia et
ceux de suez vous faites une proposition
effectivement qu'ils méritent
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous êtes
entendu quelques précisions pour ceux
qui essaient de faire la lumière sur ce
dossier
donc vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
ce que j'ignorais que vous aviez vous
même une expérience personnelle dans le
domaine de l'eau ce qui est rassurant
mais vous allez vous situer dans un
contexte qui fera de votre entreprise
un concurrent direct de veolia est donc
j'aimerais savoir dans ces conditions
comment est-ce que vous concevez alors
que pour l'instant rien n'est décidé
dans ce dossier complexe
comment vous entendez vous situer donc
au niveau national puisque c'est un peu
la préoccupation des élus qui sont ici
aujourd'hui
comment vous entendez vous situez dans
ce rapport qui existera entre
la société se s france puisque moulin
thulliez tout à l'heure comme cela et
veolia puisque on viendrait un petit peu
à une situation qui existait
précédemment entre les deux grands
majors et acteur majeur de l'eau sur le
territoire national je monsieur gilles
et peut-être va peut-être prendre la
parole dans à porter oui bien madame la
présidente monsieur le président
monsieur le président directeur général
lors de son audition par nos commissions
donc antoine frérot a pris grand soin
donc de nous préciser que le rachat par
méridien de la branche eau de suez de
constituer qu'une proposition au
bénéfice des autorités de concurrence
mais si jamais loupé a été menée à son
terme qu'est ce qui assure bien que la
cession de la branche eau se fasse selon
vos termes si la commission européenne
ne l'exigé pas ou qu un autre fonds plus
offrant pourquoi pas étranger d'ailleurs
au moins dix ans venez faire une
contre-proposition à veolia
quelles garanties avez vous aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet existe-t-il un quelconque
engagement contractuel de veolia à vous
céder ses activités
résumé par l'onu d'un engagement de
veolia à vous vendre la branche eau de
suez ou bien d'une proposition qui
finalement pourrait éventuellement vous
écarter in fine et pourriez-vous
d'ailleurs nous indiquer avec précision
la date de vos premiers échanges avec
veolia au sujet de l'offre de rachat de
ce fait ce parce que sur ce calendrier
on aimerait avoir des précisions je vous
remercie
[Musique]
monsieur le président on va vous laisser
répondre à ses premières questions et
ensuite il ya d'autres inscrits donc
qu'on leur donnera la parole vas-y la
présidente
d'abord qu'est-ce que meridiam en tant
que société de mission nous avons
dès 2007 établit une raison d'être qui
est toujours la même
aujourd'hui c'est à dire de avec nos
parties prenantes de délivrer des
infrastructures des services essentiels
pour le bien des populations et cette
société émission nous nous oblige et
nous impliquer dans la gestion
opérationnelle des actifs dans lequel
nous investissons mais nous obliger nos
implique notamment en matière de
transparence des engagements que nous
prenons et la façon dont les mettons en
oeuvre pour chacun de nos actifs pour
chacune des sociétés les investisseurs
ou sans ce meridiam du terme ont une
responsabilité dans leur objectif qui va
jusqu'à leur rémunération d'amener des
objectifs non financiers à leur terme au
même niveau que les objectifs financiers
donc nous avons des plans d'actions
puisque notre mission se décline par
rapport à un certain nombre d'objectifs
de développement durable tels que
définis par l'onu sur cinq piliers dont
les infrastructures durables
évidemment le climat mais aussi
l'égalité homme-femme et et l'accès et
l'inclusion dans le monde du travail
donc ces objectifs sont déclinées par un
indicateur pour chacun de nos actifs
pour chacun de nos projets ils sont
suivis de façon annuelle et sont
publiées revue par un comité de mission
qui a des membres indépendants et
audités par des des organismes
accrédités pour ce faire donc et dense
est dans cette optique nous avons lors
des discussions avec les laisser ceux du
groupe suez
nous leur avons proposé d'ailleurs
d'engager une démarche collective au
sein de suez de se transformer même en
société à mission parce qu'il nous
semble que le coeur de métier de l'eau
se prête bien
compte tenu des parties prenantes et dix
clients et consommateurs qu'ils
desservent à ce statut de société à
mission donc ces sociétés a mission
celle au-delà d'une raison d'être mais
c'est une mesure et et un engagement
d'arriver à cette mesure est de mettre
les moyens opérationnels financiers pour
y arriver
comme j'ai dit nous allons en effet
inclure dans le périmètre que nous
souhaitons reprendre les tous les
centres de recherche je lisais listés et
on a quelques autres plus petits qui ne
qui n'ont pas été listés dont le sire
c'est donc il est clair pour nous et
c'est un sujet de concurrence je pense
que la dg concurrence à bruxelles qui
est en charge du dossier aura comme nous
le souci que l'entité résultant de cette
fusion plus de cette séparation et tous
les moyens nécessaires qu'ils soient de
recherche et développement d'innovations
de constructions de technologie et des
brevets pour être un concurrent
indépendant autonome et faire une vraie
concurrence à veolia je pense que de ce
côté nous avons une vraie un vrai
alignement avec l'autorité de la
concurrence et l'autorité de la
concurrence sera souveraine sur son
analyse de ce périmètre en matière de ce
que cela doit délivrer en matière de
concurrence et de tous les aspects que
vous avez que vous avez mentionné
donc en ce sens je regrette évidemment
que les choses aient pris une telle
tournure ne nous sommes proposées et nos
discussions avec veolia date de
l'annoncé d' angie de vouloir vendre sa
participation avant
nous avons discuté que ce soit avec
véolia ou suez bien avant et nous étions
disponibles à tout le monde nous nous
sommes proposés parce que nous pensions
et moi je pense que les expériences
précédentes de des sociétés de services
publics comme celle de l'eau qui sont
critiques gérés par des fonds classiques
de private equity avec des horizons de
trois quatre cinq ans ne sont pas
compatibles avec ce service public parce
que on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un service essentiel que l'eau a
un coût et le coût d'investissement ne
peut pas être celui à plusieurs chiffres
que que nécessitent ces sociétés pour
faire bien leur travail c'est déjà un
grand sujet d'ailleurs même par rapport
à la bourse
parce que je ne suis pas non plus sûr
que que une pression trimestriels
boursière sur des activités comme celle
de l'eau soit une bonne chose mais ça
c'est un autre débat
je ne vais pas rentrer là dedans donc
nous avons proposé une solution parce
que nous pensions que nous avions une
solution de long terme de pérennisation
de ce champion en matière de l'eau et
une solution qui lui permette de non
seulement survivre mais de se développer
en ré investissant massivement en france
chose que je pense c'est un peu
dispersés dans cette volonté mais cette
obligation aussi d'investir aussi
massivement autant à l'international
qu'en france et donc les les arbitrages
d'investissement n'était pas toujours en
faveur de la france dans un marché
complexe et compliquée avec
une demande forte de transparence des
municipalités des collectivités qui
esprit que ce mouvement de
municipalisation nous sommes très
conscients de cette petite rupture qui a
eu lieu et de ce lien qu'il faut
retisser est-ce que la dsp
c'est la solution à tous moi je ne le
crois pas en nous gérons le port de
calais en étant le gérant mais
l'actionnaire à 40% avec eux du public à
côté dans une forme de ces maps et ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir d'efficacité de
trouver les bons moyens d'investissement
mais c'est aussi le moyen de trouver de
la transparence dans la gouvernance et
d'un alignement d'intérêt de très long
terme avec le public parce qu'il n'y a
que comme ça qu'on peut livrer et
délivrer un service de qualité aux
consommateurs
alors nos engagements avec veolia il ne
porte que sur cette opération pour
apporter une solution ils sont
réciproques
ils sont réciproques ils sont pris par
écrit et ses engagements nous amène ont
évidemment sous sous réserve une fille
née de l'accord à la fois sur le
périmètre est sûre
ces engagements de la dg comp à être la
solution est à reprendre suez aux france
et le périmètre plus large qui est
discutée aujourd'hui mais avec tous les
outils techniques d'innovations
nécessaires pour être indépendant et
concurrentiel et nous n'avons nos
engagements aujourd'hui avec veolia ne
nous limitent en aucune façon qu'entre à
la concurrence qu'on mènera veolia avec
suez le jour venu peut laisser la parole
à franck montaugé pardon et ensuite à
fabien gay merci madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président directeur
général ça me prendre position
personnelle main par rapport à la
démarche qui est qui la vôtre à l'égard
de suez je voudrais témoigner en tant
qu'élu local ancienne élue au calme et
redonne en l'occurrence de votre
implication locale puisque vous avez
repris l'usiné de biogaz du grand auch à
la base de laquelle j'étais en tant que
maire à l'époque et vous l'avez fait à
travers une structure que vous avez
évoquées qui est orga cela que je
suppose que comme vous parliez de
projets pas loin de toulouse c'était
celui-là voilà donc je vois là je
voulais témoigner de effectivement par
la très concrètement de votre
implication locale dans la dans la même
idée
quand on regarde les réalisations qui
sont les vôtres les applications qui
sont les vôtres vous avez réalisé des
projets qui touchent à la mobilité
[Musique]
un nombre important si j'ai bien compris
est-ce que cela augure dans le cadre dun
de votre rentrée éventuelle au capital
de 16 est-ce que cela augure d'une
nouvelle orientation stratégique du coup
du groupe suez et qui pourrait donc
s'intéresser par exemple la mobilité et
en particulier aux petites lignes
d'équilibré des territoires qui
intéresse le rural notamment dans sailor
dans sa relation aux métropoles c'est un
sujet important pour l'ensemble du
territoire national
donc je voudrais savoir si derrière cela
il y a une une orientation stratégique
du futur voilà futur groupe
je sais pas comment il faut l'appeler en
tout cas de la delà de la future
éventuelle nouvelle organisation de de
suez dernier point suez est déjà engagée
sur la sur le biogaz à travers la
réutilisation des déchets issus des eaux
usées vous maîtrisez à travers vos
sociétés d'autres techniques
est-ce que là aussi il y à une
confortement éventuel du groupe suez sur
la méthanisation à partir d'autres
sources que celles qui l'utilisaient
déjà je vous remercie
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le président directeur général
de questions je reviens sur la question
de madame la présidente sophie primas
sur le le montant de l'opération est ce
que ces trois est-ce que c'est plus près
de 6
c'est pas c'est pas une petite opération
pour vous et c'est notamment l'interview
que vous avez donné dans les écoles 15
septembre vous avez dit si on va sur
cette opération on le fera notamment
avec cnp assurances qui sera un
partenaire de cette opération
sauf que le 16 septembre la cnp
assurances a démenti
donc la question c'est si vous y allez
avec quels partenaires financiers parce
que c'est pas une petite opération puis
la deuxième
puisque vous nous rassurer sur sur
l'emploi en france et on n'aurait pas de
raison de ne pas vous croire puisque
vous êtes un fonds d'investissement qui
participait au pea hostile mais on a une
question précise
c'est que sur les cinq dernières années
suez a investi 5 milliards d'euros et
dans la même interview vous dites sur
les 5 à 7 à 11 à venir on prévoit
d'investir 800 millions d'euros et un
petit décalage quand même et ça fait
poser la question est ce que c'est la
r&d par exemple qui va souffrir de ce
sous investissement
et on le sait si c'est la r&d qui pâtit
de sous investissements à venir
c'est notamment sur ces questions
d'emploi et notamment dans pour en
france que nous risquons d'avoir un
souci est donc votre engagement sur cinq
ans après on peut se dire que sur après
on pourrait avoir difficulté
rassurez-nous vous nous le dites c'est
pas une opération financière c'est un
projet industriel mais un projet
industriel il a besoin d'investissements
notamment sur le long cours voilà merci
je ne vois pas d'autres mains qui se
lèvent si jean baptiste blanc voilà
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président directeur général en fait dans
le dans le prolongement de mon collègue
fabien gay je m'interroge aussi là
dessus sur votre capacité à investir
parce que ce qui interroge de manière
générale c'est votre histoire qui
récente finalement la présidente évoque
évoque une histoire française qui a plus
d'un siècle la vôtre quelques années
c'est qu'ils interrogent c'est votre
capacité à investir on vient de le dire
c'est qu'ils interrogent c'est là c'est
le fait que la capitalisation boursière
de suez ces 11 milliards et vos actifs
ces 8 milliards et puis vous venez de le
dire c'est ça qui me m'incite à prendre
la parole parce que je suis d'accord
avec vous et d'intervention mais vous
dites les dsp ne sont pas la solution à
tout alors les dsp ce sont des
délégations de service public
est ce que il ya là
vision que vous auriez de l'eau il
serait plus un service public sénateurs
sont des élus locaux et surtout c'est ça
qui les inquiète dans cette affaire suez
veolia surtout que vont devenir les dsp
que va devenir la gestion de l'eau en
france en fait
est-ce qu'il ya pas là un risque de
financiarisation qui serait contraire à
l'intérêt public des collectivités
locales
je vous remercie didier mandelli qui a
demandé la parole
merci monsieur le président je crois je
crois que nous devrions tout d'abord
nous nous réjouir d'avoir une entreprise
qui résonne sur du long terme qui ne
soit pas un fonds spéculatif donc je
voulais le dire en préambule
vous avez évoqué monsieur le président
un an des engagements écrits avec avec
véolia et notamment sur les questions de
périmètre donc moi ma question est
simple est-ce que dans le cadre de ses
engagements écrits vous avez validé par
exemple le fait de ne pas parler de
pacte de non agression ou de clauses de
non concurrence
mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous en
dira sans trahir le secret des affaires
évidemment nous en dire un peu plus sur
éventuellement les secteurs d'activité
où où les marchés sur lesquels vous
seriez engagé un pas aller
face à face à véolia tout simplement pas
d'autres questions si le président l'on
joue veut bien je poserai quelques
questions presque dans les veines de
ceux qui viennent d'être posés mais un
peu à côté une sur la recherche
aujourd'hui la recherche du groupe suez
est très importante vous avez mentionné
l'ensemble des structures en france
elle s'appuie bien sûr sur le chiffre
d'affaires de suez en france mais elle
s'appuie surtout sur le chiffre
d'affaires de suez dans le monde et donc
la structure de recherche est un
pourcentage du chiffre d'affaires dans
le monde
demain le périmètre si vous allez au
bout de cette opération de suez sera
naturellement plus réduit donc est-ce
que vous êtes prêts effectivement c'est
un petit peu la question de fabien à
maintenir le niveau en valeur absolue
d'investissement dans ses centres de
recherche pour tenir tête ou en tout cas
concurrence et votre futur concurrent
veolia sur la même question que didier
mandelli effectivement se pose la
question de la non concurrence et y at
il à un pacte de non concurrence dans le
temps avec véolia puisqu'après tout suez
dans sa nouvelle formule sera peut-être
prête à faire des investissements dans
de nouveaux secteurs où de nouveaux pays
d'ailleurs c'est à la fois les secteurs
et les pays est ce qu'il ya un accord de
non concurrence pendant quelques années
pendant combien d'années sur quel
secteur
je pense que ça c'est vraiment des
informations qui nous intéresse beaucoup
voilà on se pressait merci alors en ce
qui concerne la stratégie pour pour suez
il ya en effet comme j'ai mentionné dans
mon discours en luminaires have band
d'activités connexes et la méthanisation
en fait partie aujourd'hui nous nous
avec et leur gaz ne nous mettez nizon
déjà débout de traitement
de suez et donc ce que nous avons
proposé au corps social et au management
de suez c'est c'est en effet de de
reprendre un peu la gestion de ses
activités connexes qui pourra leur
apporter une plus value en matière de
métiers connexes
alors c'est pas forcément le cas pour la
mobilité locale mais nous continuerons à
nous en occuper directement donc je vous
rassure il y aura pas de diversion par
rapport à nos objectifs dans
l'investissement local dans la mobilité
mais mais ce sera pas forcément dans la
stratégie de suez néanmois suez aura
pour reprendre certaines activités que
meridiam portes aujourd'hui et qui sont
connexes
parce qu'il y a une une émulation à
trouver et un renforcement à trouver sur
ses nombreuses activités
en ce qui concerne les capacités
financières
alors je sais que en matière de fond les
choses peuvent être compliquées n'a pas
fait si nous avons eu huit milliards
d'euros de fonds propres à investir nos
capacités financières et nos
investissements aujourd'hui représente
65 milliards d'euros papayou millaire
drôme donc une acquisition de suez même
à 5 ou 6 milliards ne représente que 10%
de notre bilan
aujourd'hui est pas donc évidemment avec
lui milliards on peut faire beaucoup
d'autres choses c'est comme c'est le cas
pour suez ou veolia
avec des fonds propres on peut faire
beaucoup de choses et donc c'est dans ce
cadre là que nous avons d'ailleurs déjà
mobilisé plus de 8 milliards pour être
prêt à toute éventualité
pour cette nouvelle opération qui
comprendra suez aux france et un certain
nombre de pays
qui feront partie de l'international
dans le volume dans les principes sera
au niveau de celui de ce réseau france
donc à peu près doublé la taille pour
justement donner de la perspective
notamment aux employés pour justement
donné aussi de la perspective à ses
activités de construction de recherche
et développement qui avait l'habitude de
travailler sur un champ plus large avec
des pays qui ont des besoins un peu
différent du nôtre et est donc cette
perspective internationale s'il n'a pas
été révélée forcément début a toujours
été dans les discussions avec veolia
pour pour donner au groupe une assise
qui lui permettent d'être un vrai
concurrent de veolia alors pour pour ce
qui est je vous renvoie au communiqué de
la cnt qui n'a pas démenti mais qui a
confirmé qu'elle ne voulait pas faire
partie de quelques
tractations et agitation hostiles ou
dans nos styles blues en amical
en tout coordination et en toute
transparence
voilà si je on parle des engagements
écrits et la clause de non concurrence
d'abord il faut être très clair toute
clause de non-concurrence icrete avec
veolia serait illégale donc y'a aucune
ambiguïté là-dessus ceni dans notre
intérêt ni dans un an ni légale donc et
ce serait le la première chose que
la commission dans le travail précis et
profond qu'elle fait
deux membres est et demande à annuler
donc nous n'avons eu ni l'intention et
veolia non plus et je pense que la
commission sera garante du fait qu'il
n'y en a aucune
et que nous aurons toute liberté pour
concurrencer veolia dans tous les
territoires possibles et inimaginables
que qui sera possible pour suez
voilà donc et ça pour nous c'est très
clair et c'est un principe fondamental
et et de bus qui reste dans le droit
chemin de ce que la loi requiert et que
la concurrence tranquille y at il
d'autres questions j'en ai encore une
petite si je peux me permettre
moi j'aimerais comprendre parce qu'il ya
quand même dans cette tragédie grecque
là qui nous occupe depuis plusieurs
plusieurs mois maintenant je voudrais
comprendre vos relations avec l'état ce
que l'état lors de la cession des parts
de suez par angie lors des discussions
qui n'ont pas manqué évidemment
d'exister entre monsieur frérot
vous-même et l'état avant pendant et c
on comprend pas bien comment tout ça est
organisée comment tout ça est articulé
ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer un peu
sur vous vos relations avec le ministère
de l'économie et des finances sur
éventuellement je ne veux pas croire le
président de la république ne regarde
pas ce dossier puisque c'est quand même
un dossier extrêmement industriel très
important pour la france
voilà comment est ce que tout ça
s'organise commence que tout ça s'est
construit petit à petit
bien que le président longeole à la
répéter tout à l'heure on est dans le
domaine privé
mais le domaine privé mais d'une
compétence qui s'apparente à du service
public
pardon de vous poser cette question
directe mais on essaie on essaie de
décrypter de comprendre aussi l'avis du
gouvernement là dedans et le soutien ou
pas du gouvernement
notre nos discussions avec l'état se
sont limités lors de l'offre de veolia
sur de 20% d'énergies au rôle de l'état
qui est il ya le rôle de l'état qui a le
rôle de l'autorité de la concurrence qui
aussi un rôle public important et celui
là il est toujours en cours et à la main
de bruxelles lors ce qui concerne l'état
s'était était dans son rôle notamment
vis-à-vis des engagements écrits sur
l'emploi sur sur les capacités et sur la
concurrence même si c'est un sujet de
l'autorité de concurrence et c'est aussi
pour ça que nous avons formalisé
suite aux demandes de l'état sur la
capacité sur sur les engagements sur
l'emploi la r&d tous ses engagements et
que nous les avons rebaptisées ensuite
le sujet de nos relations avec l'état
s'arrête là après ça devient une un
sujet entre deux entreprises privées
donc je me suis bien gardé de savoir ni
de m'engager avec l'état au delà des
engagements forts qui sont légitimes que
l'état demande par rapport aux services
publics de l'eau et que nous avons
et nous avons accédé à toutes les
demandes en cette matière peut-être
faire une anticipation dans le temps sur
l'évolution de ces tractations puisque
finalement on sait qu'aujourd'hui le
dossier est très judiciariser la cour
d'appel de paris vient de rendre un
arrêt qui peut éventuellement faire
l'objet d'un pourvoi mais bon qui serait
pas forcément suspensif
mais pour autant on estime que au niveau
de la concurrence il faut à peu près 18
mois pour savoir quelles seraient les
obligations qui seraient faites par
l'autorité de la concurrence européenne
donc comment est ce que dans ce contexte
et dans ce qui est voué à un projet
d'entreprise que bien évidemment vous
avez construit dans le temps
comment est ce que vous voyez la
compatibilité entre ces exigences qui
viennent de deux des procès en cours et
est votre projet à vous je je
les procès en cours je vais pas porter
de jugement sur
les différentes compétences des
différents tribunaux en ce qui concerne
le droit boursier il me semble que le
que la mf l'autorité est compétente sur
le sujet donc c'est à elle de tirer les
conclusions et puis on prendra les
conclusions telles qu'elles sont je
dirais que l'agitation judiciaire c'est
pas tellement ceni montfort ni mon
appétit
donc je préfère rester en dehors et
attendre patiemment que les juges rendre
la justice et que l'autorité puisqu'elle
est compétente déclare par rapport à
notre projet et c'est pour ça que
j'étais ravi de l'opportunité de
discuter avec les irp et les
représentants
nous on a besoin de leur engagement et
leur engagement du corps social sur ce
projet donc ce temps peut être utilisée
justement pour partager leurs
interrogations les précisions notamment
sur les sujets de périmètre il peut y
avoir des imbrications ces sujets que
nous avons discuté avec eux entre les
différentes activités et il faudra faire
ça très proprement et et notamment un
sujet qui est bien remonté c'est que
nous avons aussi proposé
compte tenu du niveau de stress que tout
ça peut amener aux employés et aux
agents que qui est une mission
particulière sur les risques
psychosociaux qui soit engagé avec les c
est ce qui te met des moyens dans cette
période de transition supplémentaire
pour pour les adresser
donc voila nous nous regardons de façon
très pragmatique une entreprise qui
forcément est dans une tourmente et
qu'il faut protéger des salariés qui à
qui il faut redonner un cadre sera
parce qu'ils ont un service public à
rendre il faut assumer cette continuité
donc dans la mesure du possible nous
restons en dehors de la bataille pour
amener le peu de sérénité
disponible sur la place si nous le
pouvons et si nous avons l'opportunité
de le faire ce que nous faisons de façon
volontaire je suis désolé encore une
question autorités de la concurrence
différentes poursuites judiciaires en
tout cas affaires judiciaires dans des
tribunaux différents d une autorité de
la concurrence qui va mettre du temps
probablement à à se décider
les délais liés aux op afin et c est ce
que vous êtes prêts à attendre 12 14 16
18 mois avant d'aller au bout de cette
opération
alors les l'autorité de la concurrence
est assez souveraine dans le temps
qu'elle mais je ne pense pas qu'on
attendra 12 14 18 mois pour arriver au
bout de cette opération
après peut-être que
[Applaudissements]
le fait de détour et des périmètres peut
prendre un peu de temps
et qu'il faut y aller doucement parce
qu'il faut le faire aussi en
consultation avec le le corps social
pour éviter les déchirures un peu
violente
néanmoins oui nous sommes nous nous
sommes engagés nous nous sommes engagés
à apporter cette solution donc nous
irons jusqu'au bout pour apporter cette
solution si l'opération se fait
présidentielle on attend 25 ans sur nos
investissements donc on peut être en 16
mois
[Rires]
j'ai passé à d'autres c'est le président
longeur non moi j'ai pas notre question
est ce qui s d'autres des commissaires
de commission qui souhaite avoir des
précisions particulières
oui monsieur g merci je voulais juste
avoir des précisions vous avez parlé
justement concernant 16 ou d'une
ouverture à l'international donc de
votre projet d'ouverture à
l'international peut nous donner des
précisions sur ce sujet là c'est à dire
qu'elles sont un peu les conditions les
moyens que vous allez mobilisés pour
pour cet objectif
une fois le périmètre arrêté et il ya
plusieurs options mais qui doivent être
validés par bruxelles parce que quand on
parle de pays européens évidemment c'est
aussi sous la la décision définitive de
la dg campent les moyens aujourd'hui
toutes les activités que nous avons nous
les déployons l'international
je dirais presque que nous avons vous
nous avons d'abord été leader à
l'international avant de l'être en
france en tant que meridiam donc nous
suez aux français aujourd'hui déjà des
moyens propres pour aller à
l'international et quand je parlais de
suez internationale et de de gréement
qui ont des capacités notamment
techniques et de construction qui
aujourd'hui se déploie à l'international
c'est pour ça que aussi nous voulons
garder ce ses activités pour avoir cette
capacité de déploiement mais meridiam a
aussi un réseau aujourd'hui dans 26 pays
sur trois continents sur lequel suez
pourra s'appuyer c'est dans ce cadre là
que dans le passé nous avons pu
collaborer c'est parce qu'on pouvait
aussi apporter quelque chose
donc aucun d'abord l'international c'est
pas une nouveauté pour meriem nous
sommes une société où on a 32
nationalités
donc on a l'habitude de la culture du
déploiement international on le vit très
bien et c'est notre objectif principal
pour toutes nos activités et bien
d'autres questions non
très bien ici pas d'autres questions que
je vous remercie monsieur le président
pour les réponses aux questions qui ont
été posées et vous avez bien compris
qu'il y avait un certain nombre
d'interrogations qui se pose surtout en
matière à la fois dans le plat en
matière de service public comment tout
ça va fonctionner et c'est une
inquiétude sur le sur le territoire de
la part d d d d élus locaux qui se pose
un certain nombre de questions et je
crois qu'il est important qu'on puisse
leur apporter des réponses mais j'allais
dire des réponses qui y si l'opération
se fait dure dans le temps quoi parce
que c'est pas effectivement des des
réponses de deux circonstances c'est il
faut vraiment qu'on ait des réponses qui
durent dans le temps parce que cette
problématique en de l'eau au niveau
environnement est une problématique
importante la gestion des déchets
quelque chose de 2,2
effectivement aussi la très important
pour notre environnement donc je merci
pour pour les réponses que vous avez pu
nous apporter et pour l'éclairage que
vous nous avez donné merci
[Musique]